[Applause]
okay so today we're just going to
introduce the moves and we'll clean it
up okay so make sure you memorize the
news practice your presents don't lose
your freaking mind
okay first move say thing are you
opening he takes a seat
and it should penetrate enough to have
the spinal displacement and can you shut
the door if you take whatever steps you
need for your range you can't have it be
where you're gonna do sukiyaki you're
out of range
okay we need bread crossovers it's fine
take up just make it smooth okay so what
when I'm up here okay so it's not that
I'm sitting here waiting for this just
like didn't she would achieve - water
water on this side right I have to fill
the gap same thing here he fills the gap
not waits for the gap to be a full
fruition Lulu okay let's go first move
okay there's two sides of the form
you're going to use two different
strategies it's not quite as clear as it
was with the Vulcan of the job they have
had their obvious advantages but the
jobs very versatile so he will
eventually adopt a kind of circular and
more of a tactic my side is going to be
very quick and I'm trying to do it were
linear faster tactic so I will be trying
to new neutralize his actions so that I
can get past his barbering Jolie and get
to that spinal ring okay he'll be trying
to smother me you see and so I see
smothers me that's why I have to do
begin neutralization to get past those
things all right so on the first one he
goes on here
so the Jo comes in and you shift your
weight and you're already on the other
side of the weapon don't step out with
your center of gravity between because
you did not do that small circle don't
do this one either this just not here
it's not doing the right technique it's
not consistent with the rest of the job
strategy and then your rage gets off so
if you let's look at it he there's his
final displacement so that would be
where his finest to stay there
energy line position now I'm going to do
it front of us over and I'm going to
step out let's say I do this
so usually how that works is that he
does not ever penetrate you see here
does not ever penetrate and then this
worked you see but that first one is
wrong because he hasn't tried of
smothering me right so he's there so
so already here don't bring this one no
movies Joe not a big walk very short and
quick flip number two very short and
quick so you're gonna want to do this is
beginner one stood up down that that's
not very quick so watch that one to know
and make sure you're on target so and
again you want him to touch that hey
here's the deviation right here he's
already at 1/4 off my body on my cinema
off then I just move in he's off the Joe
angle slow okay you're going to see a
very subtle hand change so as I move the
weapon moves I fold it with this hand
I'm here and as I shift the left hand
comes back you see that well I opened
the right hat think the right hand where
it is and that's the hatching boom then
the right hand is going to come up to
the top of that just like
you've been doing okay and now I have
the plane that I want that diagonal his
webbing comes around and hit so you're
slow whoa there's the plane boom
slide crap
the stakes keep the right hand there you
see where it's at the end this is now
very awkward next to the stage you go
right out of there
then you try to transition here that's
not where you want to have a one handed
grip at every contact cannot slide very
far then you come up and you have this
little tiny rib here at the very end
when you hit that there's going to be
the equal and opposite force coming back
you don't want that edge cutting into
you give yourself something here at the
end don't mistake you don't adopt that
plane you're speaking around your head
you see you pushing it well that's not a
yen utilization you tell me exactly what
you're doing and you go round your head
look how long that's an open time it
should be gold puck we finished at the
same time he hits in his mind and I hit
his mind okay let's go
okay go blue cheap and comes straight up
you want to hide your emotion as long as
you can so you know you don't do yokomen
uchi that it comes up is it the guard is
it going to be a graph is it just coming
up for the kick so you hide it comes up
and then the elbow comes in boom boom
boom yeah Elmo does not go out it's
structurally weak this is how people get
Tennyson
okay it's a structural weakness right
there so you don't use that same thing
goes on kiss OH - you guys all picture
baseball but it's not the same dynamics
and even in a certain point we're going
to see that they turn their grip so as
he comes in we'll just get the angles
here we are don't think this let's give
me a target
I'm at the top of my head I know we hit
it from the side that's where you ever
you see because it's not going to go
here and then you go here to hit
everyone always goes around like this so
I'm going to do like I'm doing children
but I just turned my wrist turn my wrist
so I'm coming it down but I turn back
this that's the movement you say we
watch the Jo wool I come down go but I
turn my wrist that was the angle that
was all I needed and then the hip does
so he comes her out boom oh I'm coming
straight down turn my wrist oh we hit
straight down hit straight out punch run
the wrist watch the difference say can I
go around with my elbows that's a
totally different thing it's going to
take longer there's less American
tragedy on it you're not cutting through
your
cancellation is not cutting through as
many planes and it's not anatomically
correct so don't start swinging the joke
or turn your wrist so at the end you're
going to have that you're not going to
have this you see it turned my wrist I'm
here like that can't go you really get
young universe right hand left hand is
pulling it down body still turning turn
the grip can't dominate don't catch your
left hand cosmetically at the end so you
can look at the left end is you do to
the right and the right hand is given in
to the left hand
okay I'm just throwing the thing back
before
that's right right to the who because I
am basically doing this center line to
set the left hands pull straight down
just like on your committee chief that
elbow will be anchored you don't you
start to see these are anchored elbows
when you go on like that but the what
was being pulled out and so the end of
the job is higher than the house so you
can't do this
you can't be here and pull it down you
came around who you see that Joe
geometry thirdly watch you know Cohen
she's some crazy ass
what the
you're just straining your need you all
twist it up i barely able the whole
balance
what did not have that came here this
back foot went too far this foot to not
rotate lock the four corners loose with
my body
boom and as you finish four corners
move for 30 at once start to move feet
move boom I am here tension four bars
four corners boom
[Music]
bring that foot back in four bars boom
down here wrap push don't do the other
one let me get into the other one put
come on
okay let's go by the way who will not be
deceptive if I push on him so he does
his weapon if he feels that come back so
we withdraw and then you got it
remember my side strategy is via
neutralization he goes into the empty
space alright so I might have a physical
geometry true what else do I have the
side space-time - there's a time to do
it let's watch his joke his joke is
currently sailor
going from the outside to the inside you
see that if he keeps that vector and he
goes straight extended he would be
missing me
so that means jump ahead and wash it at
some point what yes he has to go from
the outside back to the inside so as I
move this would not be the right time to
try to get that over the don't is it Amy
at me no yukue Bonnie where it is home
shut I haven't done anything yet and it
starts to move to the other side that is
where my weapon comes up see that's
where it comes up now you're like okay
but here's where I want to push it no
just ride the weapon and eventually it's
gonna do what I'm just gonna come more
to the inside Duke two seconds he's
gonna drive with his left hip it was
gonna have an angle it's not perfectly
straight here and she drive drove with
his left hip turn the Jo it goes that
extra bit over so I am moving over you
see and with the rotation I'm moving
over and as a step I moved over all the
way so if I have the wrong timing
this is pushing keep going pushy pushy
you could have just gone here come on
boom do you understand I don't need the
deflection so find out the right timing
where I'm not having that deflection
angle is just an IP contact that's all
it is okay let's go so okay so he's here
he's aggressive I don't want to go like
this right I don't want to twist myself
there's a rotation first you see all
rotation I'm elbow drops and again I'm
not doing this he's pushing Tamar
oh it just disappears off the wall whole
rotation disappears get push push
grapple with the other hand push me push
you think it's not goofy
who elbow anchor big gorilla who Kimmy
[Music]
rooty disappear fool earnest this would
be totally different to his body
you think he's gonna hit he's gotta feel
I got you Oh